thousands rally in our nation's capital
for the defeat the mandates march
speaking out and growing frustration
over controversial vaccine requirements
all across our country will wet
organized the rally and he joins us now
hey will
good morning good morning how did it go
why did you organize this
it went better than we ever could have
hoped for 50 000 people at the lincoln
memorial coming and standing up for
their freedoms basically telling the the
bureaucrats the corporations the the bad
politicians that we don't want to take
this anymore and that we're coming and
standing up for our freedom and to have
so many people from all across the
country come and show their support just
it was absolutely incredible and well
you're not against vaccines right just
against mandates
right the march was about the mandates
it was about these draconian measures
that these people are putting on to us
that are making people lose their jobs
their livelihoods many people i mean
look what's happening with children
right now with their uh
their social skills and all of that so
that is what it is all about it is about
fighting for our freedoms have you heard
from any leaders have they have you
changed anyone's minds
after the rally we haven't heard from
anyone yet but we're hoping to hear from
him soon and in my speech i actually
brought a constitution and brought it up
on stage if there were any politicians
watching because i don't think many of
them have ever seen that document before
from what it seems and you've had
republicans and democrats supporting you
right
yes it's on both sides you know there
was a black lives matter supporter who
was speaking actually right after me and
you know myself i'm more a conservative
person and so it was everyone coming
together to say this is about our
freedom what is america america is a is
the country that was founded on
individual liberty and we want to be
able to make choices for our own body
and for our own american spirit what are
some of the stories you've heard about
people that were forced to leave their
work
yeah i mean there were countless doctors
who had lost their jobs who had been
silenced off social media there were
people there who were vaccine injured
there were people who were firefighters
who lost their jobs i actually worked
very closely here in los angeles with
firefighters for freedom who have lost
their jobs because of the mandates and
this is happening from people who just a
year ago were considered heroes in this
country and now are cast out onto the
streets is nothing because they don't
want to get this vaccine it should be
their choice well will what how did you
get involved in this you seem pretty
young i'm pretty impressed that you
organized a march in washington
thank you i'm not the main organizer
there were some other people i was
mostly speaking but i was able to get
involved because i've been someone who's
been very adamant about speaking out
against this and seeing what this
administration is prioritizing right now
it's it's it's unheard of this is an
unprecedented time in america and so if
there's something that i can do to speak
out and fight for truth i'm always going
to do that i know robert f kennedy jr
was one of the organizers dr robert
malone was there speaking there were
some great christian artists that were
playing as well thank you so much will
great job
god bless you guys thank you too thank
you